bonsoir nous sommes le 14 novembre merci
de nous rejoindre pour une nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction en
direct à 18h comme chaque soir de la
semaine et voici les principaux titres
que nous allons développer au cours de
la prochaine demi-heure au côté des
parents les enseignants se mobilisaient
aujourd'hui contre les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires qui se mettront en place
partout dès la rentrée prochaine
mobilisation suivie nous ferons le point
pour les Ies une TVA qui va passer de 7
à 20 % pour les activité équestre la
grogne monte dans les ivelines d'autant
que le département est le premier en
terme de licencié pour en parler
Christine Boutin sera sur ce plateau la
conseillère générale est en charge de ce
dossier et elle monte au cré et puis ce
14 novembre c'était la journée mondiale
de lutte contre le diabète il y aurait 4
millions de Français concernés dont près
d'un demiillion qui l'ignorerait le
diabète qui entraîne parfois des dégâts
irréversibles notamment des accidents
cardio-ovasculaires plusieurs opérations
de sensibilisation se sont tenu l'image
du jour c'est cette université de
versailles- Saint-Quentin mal enlo si
l'on en croit à la lettre envoyée par
son président Jean-Luc vessier à
l'ensemble du personnel une lettre qui
s'est retrouvée hier sur internet sur
plusieurs blog blogs il manquerait 4
millions d'euros à l'université sur les
19 nécessaires pour boucler le budget
jusqu'au 31 décembre de cette année
l'État aurait consenti une rallonge mais
en demandant en échange la suspension
immédiate par l'Université du du
règlement de ces factures et de tous les
nouveaux engagements cela s'appelle une
cessation de paiement en cause des
embauches trop nombreuses des
investissements immobilier qui coûte
très cher la faculté de médecine dont le
loyer atteint les 750000 € ou encore les
quelques 900000 € de coût de
fonctionnement de l'observatoire le
président de l'université refuse de
s'exprimer face à la presse sur ce
dossier pour l'instant de son côté le
syndicat unf tient ce jeudi soir une
réunion à destination des étudiants pour
les informer et tenter de proposer des
solutions tout enortant un regard
critique sur les choix de la direction
ces dernières
années pour l'instant la réforme des
rythmes scolaires ne concerne que 20 %
des écoles françaises don les
établissements de la ville de trappe
mais 2 mois après sa mise en vigueur la
fronde s'amplifie après les animateur
mardi les enseignants ont manifesté
devant la mairie de Trapp puis devant
l'inspection académique à Guill en
courours Anthony rche pour les
précisions de cette journée de
mobilisation tous protestent évidemment
contre le passage à la semaine de 4
jours et demi mais aussi contre la
journée de récupération instaurée par
l'Éducation nationale pour compenser le
lundi 2 septembre jour de prérentrée
pendant lequel les enfants n'ont pas eu
cours réunis tout d'abord dans une école
de trappe les enseignants grévistes ont
ensuite manifesté leur colère devant les
vitres de la mairie ses instituteurs
yvelinois estiment que la réforme payon
est tout sauf égalitaire l'application
de des nouveaux rythmes scolaires va
être différent d'une commune à une autre
pour faire très simple et
malheureusement très vrai dans les
communes riches tu aura des moyens pour
mettre des animations facilement en
place et dans les communes pauvres ou
plus en difficulté il en sera
complètement autrement à trrappe 70 %
des enseignants étaient en grève et un
peu moins de 50 % sur l'ensemble du
département devant les portes de
l'inspection académique les syndicats ne
sont pourtant pas opposés à une réforme
mais ils demandent une réelle
concertation ce que nous réclamons c'est
une réflexion qui s'engage et qui permet
de repenser le disposit
et de réfléchir au à la meilleure
opportunité pour faciliter le travail
des élèves dans les classes à en courour
pour la première fois plus de 60 % des
enseignants étaient en grève le maire à
la tête du collectif contre la réforme
n'entend pas l'appliquer tant qu'elle
n'aura pas été chiffrée la mairie de
Paris c'est la panique générale ils
avaient budgeté 100 millions ils on sont
à 60 millions erreur de 600 % vous voyez
en cours moi j'achète un produit 10 qui
vaut 10 et après je facturai 60 à mes à
mes administrés non mais ils me jettent
dehors ils ils a ils auront raison cette
réforme ne verra pas le jour en tout cas
elle en cours tant que je n'aurai pas un
audit de combien ça coûte qui paye et à
quoi ça sert vraiment les enseignants
élinois compent participer au
rassemblement prévu le 20 novembre
prochain devant le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale pour réclamer une
autre réforme pour
l'école chaque soir dans ce journal vous
réagissez à l'actualité que pensez-vous
de cette grève faut-il repenser la
réforme en cours de cette éducation
nationale vos réponses avec ce micro
trottoir à mon avis le rythme scolaire
il est bien est bien bien structuré donc
je crois ils vont garder ils vaut mieux
garder le le rythme maintenant pour le
pour l'instant oui tout à fait parce que
question organisation je pense que c'est
vraiment difficile la réformé non moi je
pense pas honnêtement comme je v pas
vous paraître vieux jeu mais à notre
époque on all les 4 jours et demi à
l'école par semaine et c'était très bien
moi je dis passer l'avoir passé à 4
jours je trouve que c'est une bêtise les
enfants sont trop F fatigué oui je pense
parce que elle est difficile à mettre en
place c'est surtout ça sinon c'est une
très bonne idée mais après il va falloir
trouver le budget surtout la la budgéé
quoi parce que beaucoup de de communes
ont pas les moyens ça aura pu être
positif mais si on se compare aux autres
pays je pense que par exemple comme
l'Allemagne ils font beaucoup de sport
dans les après-midis et ça serait bien
pour les jeunes pour nos enfants ce
jeudi 14 novembre c'est la journée
mondiale du diabète une maladie qui
concerne plus de 350 millions de
personnes dans le monde attrape
l'Institut de promotion de la santé
organisé une une vaste campagne de
promotion de prévention de dépistage le
reportage de yolen
Torz donc là le taux de sucre dans le
sein est trop élevé ah d'accord donc il
faut rééquilibrer votre régime ou votre
traitement pour le diabète ok ok felppé
a appris qu'il était diabétique il y a 4
ans ce matin le contrôle de glycémie le
prouve son taux de sucre dans le sang
est trop élevé par rapport à la normale
il profite de cette journée mondiale de
dépistage et de prévention du diabète
pour mieux comprendre sa maladie c'est
d'avoir les formations supplémentaires
c'est de rencontrer les gens qui ont de
mêmes problèmes que moi et parfois on
parle ensemble et puis parfois bon il y
a beaucoup de choses parfois que
j'arrive de mal à comprendre et par
rapport à eux et ça me fait comprendre
quoi ça m'aide on estime aujourd'hui
environ 3500000 diabétiques en France
avec 400 nouveaux cas par jour c'est
aussi une maladie dite silencieuse
résultat 700000 personnes seraient
diabétiques sans le savoir souvent les
premiers symptômes n'alarmment pas des
signes de fatigue des vertigge ou encore
quelques sueurs froidees bien souvent
mais ça sur le compte du travail on dit
bon ben on travaille beaucoup donc
aujourd'hui je suis fatigué c'est un
coup de fatigue et puis alors c'est pour
ça que quand son faut faire un bilan
tous les ans voir avec son médecin son
médecin traitant de façon tous les ans
faire une analyse une prise de sang ça
coûte rien au quand ils font un bilan
complet en même temps ils font une prise
de sang pour la glycémie et puis on voit
si déjà ça donne une
indication le dépistage peut en effet
limiter les risques de complication car
pour certains le diabète peut vite
devenir une maladie contraignante j'ai
pas dormi de la nuit je stresse beaucoup
c'est une maladie
diabète qui qui atteint le stress
physiquement tout ça on est des minuit
et c'est le matin c'est des fois c'est
très dur pour pour la journée
quoi les complications du diabète
peuvent être très sévères trouble de la
vision céité accident cardio-vasculaire
voire même l'amputation d'un membre
selon l'Organisation Mondiale de la
Santé en 2030 cette maladie deviendrait
globalement la 7e cause de
mortalité je reçois ce soir dans le 7
suite lactu Christine Bouttin bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau conseillère
général des Yvelines en charge de la
mission cheval une mission importante
lorsque l'on sait que le département est
le premier dans ce domaine en terme de
licencié avec 22000 adhérents 1er
janvier 2014 la TVA pour les activités
équestre et qui passe de 7 à 20 % et
vous dites que cela va entraîner des
suppressions de postes c'est toute une
filière toute une économie qui est mise
à mal vous savez les les centres
etquaiss sont très nombreux
effectivement dans les ivelines et les
personnes ce sont des petites entreprise
et les personnes qui animent ces centres
etquaiss sont des passionnés ils
comptent pas du tout leur temps et leur
bilan mensuel est toujours très ricraque
parce que parce que voilà c'est c'est
pas très rentable cette affaire c'est
vraiment un truc de passionné et donc le
fait de passer de 7 à à 20 % va mettre
en péril ses ces centres donc il va y
avoir des suppressions d'emploi sans
compter l'euthanasie des chevaux enfin
je veux dire c'est c'est et sur le plan
social toutes les conséquences par
exemple pour les handicapés pour les
prisons le le cheval est un médiateur
social et donc c'est c'est une
catastrophe vraiment 185 centres
équestres dans le département un millier
d'emplois vous les avez consulté ces
différents centres comment le conseil
général peut les soutenir et même les
soutient déjà aujourd'hui écouté déjà
merci de me donner la parole pour dire
que nous dénonçons cela il y a un
certain nombre de manifestations il y en
a une qui a eu lieu le 11 novembre je
crois qu'il y en a d'autres qui sont
prévus aujourd'hui il y a une espèce de
de bras de fer avec le gouvernement car
le gouvernement s'était engagé à ne pas
faire cette augmentation alors je crois
qu'ils sont en train de réfléchir les
pauvres parmi tous leurs problèmes à à
d'autres d'autres possibilités qui
serait accordé au centrecest mais c'est
vital et il y a pas que pour le
département des ivelines il y a 8000
emplois en France qui sont à la clé et
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas des
histoires c'est pas du mensonge c'est la
réalité l'équilibre économique de ces
centres est excessivement fragile donc
20 % et puis ça veut dire que ça va
devenir un sport de riche alors que
justement le ce qui est intéressant dans
dans ces centres c'est que le
développement du cheval dans notre
département c'est que c'est devenu un
sport populaire et donc si ça passe à 20
% effectivement il y a que les riches
qui pourront continuer à faire du cheval
on va se rendre à gazerand notamment où
se trouve l'un de ces centres équestres
on va écouter différents témoignages
avec ce reportage de yolen Torz et puis
on revient ensuite en plateau pour
continuer la discussion avec Christine
Bouttin Catherine ger le hara de
gazerand depuis 26 ans sur les cinq
salariés qu'elle emploie elle envisage
peut-être de supprimer un poste à cause
de la future taxe moi je C des clients
voilà qui pourront pas suivre voilà et
puis et ben après devoir licencier parce
que si on a moins de de chiffre
d'affaires moins de rentrée on pourra
pas garder tout le personnel le GHN dont
je fais partie est estimé qu'il y aurait
à peu près 6000 postes en France qui
vont être supprimés à cause de cette
augmentation de TVA les petites
structures qui étaient déjà affaiblies
un petit peu avec la crise risquent de
pas s'en remettre ah oui ça c'est
certain les centres équestres ont déjà
connu des remous concernant leur TVA
mais celle annoncée pour l'année
prochaine et de loin la plus menaçante
pour eux selon la Fédération Nationale
du cheval 2000 entreprises seraient en
péril en 2004 la filière équestre
bénéficiit d'une TVA réduite à 5,5 %. à
l'époque l'objectif était de promouvoir
l'équitation il y a 2 ans elle était
passée à 7 %. l'année dernière une
activité était déjà passée à 19,6 %
celle du commerce des chevaux sport et
loisirs là aussi sous la pression de
l'Union européenne à noter que le
commerce des chevaux d' et de
consommation lui reste taxé à hauteur de
7 %. l'année prochaine ce seront toutes
les activités du centre équestre qui
passeront à 19,6 %. menacé d'une saisine
de la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne pour manquement sur
manquement et d'une amende de plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros le
gouvernement veut se mettre en
conformité rapidement un coup dur pour
le département des ivelines avec 21000
licenciés et plus de 200 centres il est
le deèe département équestre de France
derrière le Nord à rambouiller Débora ne
craint pas la fermeture de son
entreprise qu'elle estime viable pour
autant elle ne comprend pas cette hausse
de la TVA dans l'équitation
contrairement aux autres sports les
subventions sont quasi inexistantes ce
sont surtout des établissements
professionnels du coup il est parfois
difficile pour les gérants de se faire
une marge réelle les frais de
fonctionnement sont très lourds les
structures coûtent
cher le les chevaux demandent beaucoup
d'entretien il mangent enfin il demande
à ce qu'on s'occupe d'eux pas 5 jours
sur 7 et pas 35 heur comme une
entreprise qui ferme ses portes ou un
gymnase donc voilà nous c'est 7 jours
sur 7 s'ils sont malades c'est 24 heur
sur 24 et ben tout ça ça se paye quoi ça
un cout d'après le groupement épique
national sur les 250000 chevaux que
comptent les centres d'équitation 80000
seraient envoyés à l'abattoir pour se
faire entendre les professionnels se
mobilisent dans le département ils ont
organisé une opération escargot ce jeudi
et leur groupe FaceBook créé il y a
quelques jours compte déjà plus de 700 s
abonnés et ils sont à peu près 900
aujourd'hui 14 novembre au cours de ce
sujet on a entendu la raison he de cette
hausse de la TVA c'est une obligation
européenne la France a été sanctionnée
par la Cour de justice de l'Union il
faut augmenter cette TVA 20% la France
n'a pas le choix le gouvernement s'était
engagé vis-à-vis de la filière équestre
à faire en sorte que l'on mène la la le
bras de fer jusqu'à la procédure
judiciaire et elle n'a pas été entamée
le gouvernement ne l'a pas fait n'a pas
tenu son engagement vis-à-vis de la
filière équestre donc pour vous il y a
encore des recours possibles au niveau
euré sûr mais bien sûr tous les cas vous
savez c'est c'est vraiment faire de la
politique à courte vue parce que s'il y
a vraiment 8000 emplois qui sont
supprimés vous voyez les conséquences
économiques que ça représente c'est
c'est c'est vraiment pas possible quoi
euh 8000 emplois dans toute la France
donc la le gain qui sera apporté par la
différence entre 7 % et et 20 % ne sera
pas compensé par les 8000 euh chômeurs
supplémentaires qu'il faudra indemniser
bien sûr à l'échelle du département on
peut imaginer le Conseil Général venir
en aide à ces différentes structures
peut-être la TVA augmenter à 20 % je je
je ne sais pas parce que le Conseil
général est lui-même pris dans des dans
des contraintes budgétaires qu'il ne
connaissait pas il y a quelques années
mais enfin il est très vigilant et et
nous nous regarderons ce qu'il est
possible de faire en tous les cas moi je
ferai tout ce que je peux pour sauver
cette filière pour aider cette filière
absorb la hausse le gouvernement qui
propose que les contrats conclus avant
le 31 décembre 2013 continue à
bénéficier de ce taux réduit jusqu'à
leur terme et de plus une aide au centre
équestre va être mise en place par
l'intermédiaire d'un fond cheval ce n'a
pas encore été vraiment précisé parce
que c'est des bonnes pistes écoutez tout
ce qui pourra les aider éviter le le
chômage supplémentaire je trouve que ce
sont une bonne pistes nouvelle
manifestation prévue le 19 novembre à
Paris manifestation que les
organisateurs annoncent suivi ce sera
porte de versaill au cours au même
moment se tiendra le Congrès des mares
d'ailleurs pour autant le gouvernement
ne semble pas prêt à faire machine
arrière puisqu'il y a tout de même eu la
publication du décret d'abrogation du
TVA de la TVA aut réduit au cours de la
semaine c'était mercredi 13 novembre
vous pensez pouvoir faire puer le
gouvernement ventv mais vous savez le
gouvernement il va tellement mal que je
sais même pas s'il sera là encore le 17
le 19 novembre on va parler avec vous on
va profiter de votre présence sur ce
plateau parler d'un autre sujet votre
avenir politique vous êtes conseillère
général des ivelines vous étiez aussi
présidente du Parti chrétien déémocrate
que vous avez fondé en 2009 vous avez
démissionné début juillet pour un projet
européen vaste autour de la défense de
la fem et des valeurs morales c'est ce
que vous avez déclaré à l'époque à nos
confrères du journal Le Monde où on est
ce projet aujourd'hui mais écoutez il
avance bien j'aurai l'occasion d'en
parler soit à la fin de l'année soit au
début de l'autre mais voilà tout tout se
met en
place voilà je je peux pas vous en dire
davantage aujourd'hui sinon que je
trouve que les choses avancent vraiment
bien et que j'ai les hommes et les
femmes qui sont à mes côtés pour mener
ce projet puisque ce sera de toute façon
des listes pas uniquement en
île-de-fance mais dans toute la France
dans les 8 circonscriptions franç
à ça sera le nom de de vos listes qui
sont qui sont proposé sur l'ensemble de
la France vous serez candidat en France
absolument je serê de liste en
île-defance oui on va retrouver quel
genre de tendance politique sur ces
différentes listes parce qu'il y a déjà
eu des annonces qui ont été faites on le
sait à un moment il avait été question
de Béatrice bourge qui avait été voilà à
la tête de la manifestation contre le
mariage homosexuel avec le printemps
français on a aussi un ancien
vice-président du Front national
absolument oui est tour
présent oui absolument et puis il y a
aussi monsieur renard qui est
actuellement président des associations
famillales catholique française et
européennes et puis il y en aura
d'autres vous verrez et si on vous
attaque sur les rapprochements entre le
Front national avec les
différestion monsieur Martinez d'abord
c'est des attaques que j'attends mais
monsieur Martinez n'est plus au Front
national il me semble qu'à l'UMP
monsieur Peltier était aussi au Front
national personne ne fait cette remarque
moi je ça m'itgal ce ce qui est certain
c'est que Monsieur Martinez est un
militant pour la vie depuis plus de 30
ans donc c'est ça ce qui m'intéresse moi
je suis une femme de conviction de nom
de cette liste force vie cet engagement
qui est né de l'engagement contre le
mariage pour tous dans un non non non
non non c'est un petit peu ce qui a
déclenché le la suite la continuité non
non non non non non c'est aujourd'hui la
nécessité d'avoir une parole forte sur
des conviction ferme ce sera pas le seul
axe de programme europé Absolum mais la
vie mais la vie dans la vie vous allez
voir dans ce programme c'est pas la vie
uniquement de l'embryon ou de la fin de
vie c'est la vie de journaliste la vie
de chef d'entreprise la vie du du
responsable du centre éc c'est la vie du
médecin c'est la vie de l'ouvrier c'est
quelque chose de très concret et comment
est-ce que l'on réagit à cette à cette
problématique de chacun d'entre nous par
rapport à cette Europe qui se construit
moi je suis profondément européenne
l'engagement contre le mariage pour tous
qui se poursuit vous en pensez quoi ah
ben je pense que de toute façon cette
loi il faudra la supprimer donc elle
sera sup manifestant sont encore dans la
rue il y a quelque fois des dérapages
aussi oui ben qu'il y ait des dérapages
il y en a trop je ne sais pas s'il y en
a pour cela veilleur pour moi c'est
c'est pas un dérapage c'est simplement
montrer on a vu des manifestants de Man
pour tous se dénoncer s'opposer à cette
loi du mariage pour tous en s'attaquant
à la ministre cher Monsieur cher
Monsieur
euhou bah écoutez c'est les attaques
racistes de Madame tobira je les
condamne naturellement mais je je trouve
assez surprenant moi qui chaque jour et
des attaques mais permanentes depuis des
années et des années ça ne réveille
personne et ça tout le monde s'en fout
bon alors très bien je ne voudrais pas
non plus que les attaques dont a été
l'objet madame tobira que je dénonce
cache lesincompétences du gouvernement
et du pouvoir en politique actuel et
vous parlez des attaques à votre
encontre vous aait encore été mentionné
hier d'ailleurs vous avez tweeté à ce
sujet là c'était dans une série télé sur
France 2 on a fait des comparaisons pas
forcément très très flatteuses ça vous a
pas forcément vous avez pas forcément
apprécié hein non parce que surtout
aujourd'hui si vous voulez on nous casse
les pieds avec cette histoire de racisme
la France je le dis très fermement n'est
pas raciste la France n'est pas raciste
quand on a traité monsieur Sarkozi de
singe personne n'a parlé de racisme
alors ça va bien je dénonce cette cette
une de minutes on aurait mieux fait de
pas en parler plutôt que de faire de la
publicité à minute qui est un journal
qui n'est pas diffusé il y a derrière
tout ça toute une instrumentalisation
politicienne que je dénonce aussi
profondément en tout cas vous serez
candidat aux européennes en
l'île-de-fance et vous aurez l'occasion
de revenir pour nous en parler on va
juste conclure cet entretien en évoquant
votre succession à la tête du parti
chrétiendémocrate il y a deux candidats
qui s'affrontent actuellement les
électeurs les membres de votre parti
puisque vous êtes toujours adhérent
absolument prononcé d'ici à ce weekend
Jean-Frédéric Poisson d'un côté est
député de la 10e circonscription des
Yvelines sur Rambouillet votre secteur
vous le connaissez donc forcément bien
il est opposé à Frédéric de lettrre
membre de ce parti depuis 2 ans vous
avez un favori écoutez les deux sont
excellents et je ne me prononcerai pas
mais tout le monde sait très bien que
jean-fééric poisson était mon directeur
de cadem pendant 10 ans je connais ses
qualités mais monsieur de Let que j'ai
eu au téléphone il y a un quart d'heure
est un excellent candidat aussi
Jean-Frédéric Poisson qui est avec nous
ce soir en ligne bonsoir à vous bonsoir
merci d'être d'être en ligne pour le
journal de la rédaction de TV je
voudrais juste votre sentiment on ne
conna pas encore les résultats à cette
élection interne au parti chrétien
démocrate mais déjà tout simplement
pourquoi avoir brigué cette présidence
et puis comment vous sentez un petit peu
la la situation à l'heure
actuelle vous savez quand c'est une
campagne dont le vote se déroule de
manière électronique et puis c'est une
campagne qui a été également assez
courte donc c'est pas facile d'avoir un
sentiment
précis je connais bien cette formation
pour avoir participé à fondation pour
salu chistinein qui est sur votre
plateau et voilà j'ai l'impression quand
même que les adhérents du parti chré
démocrate devrait n désigner samedi
comme leur président maintenant nous
attendons des résultats pour avir une
forte mobilisation des électeurs
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je n'ai pas
de d'estimation de participation on sera
tous à samedi ditir j'ai brigué cette
présidence parce que je crois que le
parti crétidémocrate dans situation
actuelle de la France à une place à
prendre un rôle à jouer et un message à
porter et voilà il me semblait que je
pouvais faire partie de ceux qui
porterai ce message et si vous êtes élu
président vous vous inscrirez dans la
continuité ce qui a été fait par
Christine Boutin vous savez j'ai
participé à la fondation de cette
formation politique a maintenant 12 ans
j'en ai été le vice-président depuis
l'origine j'ai soutenu le parti
chrétiensdémocrate et et Christine
depuis maintenant près de 20 ans donc je
suis pas en train de préparer la
révolution si vous voulez d'abord c'est
pas mon style premièrement et
deuxièmement je pense qu'il y a
suffisamment de richesse dans l'héritage
dont nous sommes porteurs et dans ce que
nous défendons pour effectivement
s'inscrire dans une forme de continuité
après les temps changeent la couleur
peut-être la tonalité le l'ordre des
priorité sera peut-être un peu différent
mais malheureusement l'état de la France
justifie consion sur notre lancé merci
jean-fredéric isson d'avoir été en ligne
avec nous nous aurons l'occasion de de
revenir sur le résultat de cette
élection dans les prochains jours
puisque les résultats seront connus au
coup cours du weekend Jean-Frédéric
Poisson si jamais il devait prendre la
la succession vous garderiez un œil sur
ce qu'il va faire d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous allez continuer à rester adhérente
au parti
chrétiendémocrateprès j'ai même
l'honneur d'être présidente d'honneur
donc du Parti Chrétien-Démocrate puisque
le Bureau politique en a décidé ainsi et
je vous en remercie naturellement je je
je je serai toujours membre du Parti
Chrétien-Démocrate mais ma campagne
était la campagne des européennes est
indépendante du parti chrétienémoc
rétiémocrate merci Christine Boutin
d'être venue sur ce plateau je rappelle
également votre engagement contre la
hausse de la TVA dans les centres
équestes et puis cette candidature aux
élections européennes dont nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler puisque ça se
déroulera juste après les municipales de
mars merci à vous merci vous on va
terminer ce journal avec un reportage
culturel à présent pas toujours simple
de trouver des financements quand on
veut se lancer dans le cinéma il existe
aujourd'hui des plateformes participatif
qui aide au financement paul Antoine
Veillon vient de tourner à Rambouillet
il a bénéficié de ce système pour
compléter le budget de son premier court
métrage voici son
témoignage tournage en forêt de
Rambouillet c'est la ville où a vécu
pendant 15 ans paul- Antoine Veillon il
y revient pour son premier courtmétrage
usurpe-toi le récit d'un jeune homme de
20 ans Victor passionné de bande dessiné
qui cherche savoix artistique une
rencontre va changer sa vie paul Antoine
en est le réalisateur et le comédien
principal autour de lui une équipe de
choc comme il dit un esprit solidaire et
collectif indispensable pour mener à
bien ce projet car pas simple de boucler
son budget le réalisateur a fait appel à
une plateforme de financement
participative 1700 € collecté c'est des
sites qui existent sur Internet où en
fait on envoie à plein plein de gens et
ceux qui ont envie de participer à voilà
à la culture française au cinéma
français bah voilà il contribu et du
coup on est super heureux d'avoir eu je
crois plus de 50 coproducteurs sur sur
ce film parce que ça donne voilà ça
donne confiance et on se dit qu'on est
soutenu par plein de gens et du coup on
a pas envie de lescevoir et on sent
qu'on est suivi et ça nous donne
beaucoup de pêche une forme d'te qui a
permis à Paul Antoine de compléter son
budget de 2500 € dans un mois le
coursmétrage devrait être terminé il
restera à le faire vivre artistiquement
ce sera alors la course au
festival le journal revient demain pour
un nouveau point complet sur
l'information locale restez avec nous ce
soir vous avez notamment rendez-vous
avec Claire Cambier pour le magazine fil
echo excellente
soirée